we're doing something a little different
again today I'm going to be speaking to
dr. Peter Boghossian who's a full-time
faculty member in Portland State
University's philosophy department as
well as author of the book a manual for
creating atheists on our full program
today our regular sort of daily
political stories are going to be on
today's bonus show so yet more incentive
to become a subscriber to the David
Pakman show Peter it's always great to
talk to you I want to start first
digging into a book a manual for
creating atheist in a little more detail
and and as you know I'm going to be
using portions of that book in an
upcoming course I'll be teaching as an
adjunct professor at Boston College so
certainly I think that there's huge
value to this book but there's some
ideas in it I'd love to dig in to a
little more with you and to start maybe
you could familiarize the audience with
how you define faith in the book for the
purposes of exploring it further okay if
it's okay I'd like to take a step back
from that and talk about what the
purpose of the book is who are the
purpose of the book is to this one big
word in the whole book and that's
epistemology and that basically means
how you know what you know the purpose
of the book is to help people become
more reflective to examine their
epistemology is to examine the way they
know things and it's to help people
engage in civil conversations and there
are now literally hundreds of more than
thousands of these online and YouTube in
which people take the techniques from
the book as a template and personalize
that right have conversations with other
people about their metaphysical beliefs
faith based basically any beliefs so
that being said faith has many many
definitions
Loftis described unlocks describes as
leap over probabilities as pretending to
know something you don't know as
insufficient evidence to warrant belief
in a claim but yet you decide to believe
anyway there are many many definitions
of faith first Peter I mean the Hebrews
111 has a definition in the Bible of
faith the cronniss faith is not
explicitly defined evidence of things
unseen is the unhoped-for and a couple
with hope so the the there are many many
definitions and among the most important
thing in these conversations is that we
clarify what we mean by our terms right
from the get-go so how do you define
faith what are the two ways you define
faith in the book our define faith as I
think I defined faith through three or
four days but pretending to know things
you do not know phrase is also believing
anyway I know you asked me for two but
it's hard to pin a doubts to believing
anyway when you're going to believe
something just because you want to
believe it basically because your moral
mind over override your rational mind
well belief and if without evidence was
the other one I was thinking of in
addition blue pretending to know things
you don't know yeah belief about
sufficient evidence sufficient is a key
word there because you can have evidence
for a lot of things but that's not
sufficient to warrant a confidence in a
belief my I've been thinking about the
word pretending in that first definition
you gave pretending to know things you
don't know I don't know that that's that
common I mean a lot of people are
probably not pretending that they more
than likely in based on the
conversations I've had with people they
believe things that you and I might say
you can't actually know that based on
the available evidence so talk about
your decision to include the word
pretending to know things you don't know
if that was the case why would they have
crises of faith why does everybody say
they have Christ you don't have a crisis
that a pencil sharpener exists or no I
think that's fair but that that still
doesn't mean at some point one might
have a realization all this time I've
believed to know things that were not
supported by evidence but it's still
very difficult to say that at any point
someone is pretending to know something
they don't know I don't know I'm just
sort of throwing it out there yeah no no
it's a totally legitimate reasonable
question I had I am you know Ryan
Bella's the guy who tried to live
without God for a year and then became
an atheist now he's an interesting guy
he does here's a movie that's coming on
about that journey of it different he
just tried to live a year without God he
was a pastor in LA at a
we had a formidable flock to use that
word and then he decided to try to live
a year without God and I had a
conversation with him he is a a movie
coming out directed by and Emory Emory
be out any time now about his journey
and he he pressed me on that and I would
urge people to watch that conversation
because at the end of the conversation
he said yeah you know what I
I really didn't know and I had gaps in
my understanding of things and I made
those gaps up and I'm paraphrasing
obviously I made those gaps up by
pretending and and I'm not saying
everybody is pretending I think that
there are certainly some people who are
suffering from legitimate religious
delusions about talking snakes and you
know what have you these people aren't
pretending they're actually delusional
but but many people I can't give you a
percentage but many people pretend to
know something and I gave a talk on this
and at the greater humanist of Portland
it's online I think it's called faith
pretending to know things you don't know
where I lay out and explain the
differences that's why people by the way
make that leap between mixing up the
definition of faith with hope and trust
and they do that because there's you
don't have to pretend anything when you
hope for some you know for anything I
want
Sam Harris's I can hope for a diamond
the size of refrigerator in my own
backyard but I need to pretend that when
you have faith in something you have
confidence it extends beyond the warrant
of evidence and to make up for that
confidence you need something usually
that something is faith and usually
people that little gap that little space
in there between the evidence you have
and the confidence you have in that
belief has to be made up somehow I think
that's interesting because from my
perspective I mean as you know and most
of my audience knows I'm basically on
board with what it is we're talking
about here and your point of view but I
do think that there are sometimes more
gray areas than I like to admit when it
comes to faith and evidence and just to
sort of put this idea out there in some
sense
couldn't we say any inductive reasoning
requires some of what we might
colloquially describe as faith and I'll
give an example right so if I were to
make an assertion like I have faith that
Jesus Christ is God or whatever right
that's pretty clear to to you and to me
as yeah a basic epistemological
intervention of the types you you sort
of walk people through in your book can
get many people to reconsider that
particular faith statement but in the
same way we might believe a gravity is
uniform across our universe we don't
really have what I would even call
substantial evidence for that we've
studied or observed like a tiny fraction
of the universe we're using inductive
reasoning and if we really look at sort
of the philosophical definition of
knowledge a justified true belief that
might be a faith type belief that
gravity functions the same way across
our universe wouldn't it uh well we
really don't pack that that's a lot
there Sean Carroll the physicist Sean
Carroll calls it with that idea that
there that does a in Victor Stenger also
had roots inside well that that there's
a uniformity of gravity look first of
all in our physicist so I can't resort
but conceptually I think it applies
right right right but we wouldn't we
wouldn't say that we had faith we would
say we have a suspicion our confidence
that we can extrapolate from this corner
of the universe and the physical
phenomena gravitational waves etcetera
found in this corner of the universe
that we can extrapolate from that and
say that there's a universality of that
here's the difference and this was a big
lightbulb moment for me yes um people
usually use this to say well you have
faith your wife loves you
all right so let's I'm just going to
back away just for a moment and I'll get
back to the induction for sure yep
the issue with then is that your wife is
a real person who lives with you
we don't have anything there's even
people David's a lot of people do
Fitzgerald Bob price et cetera who cast
doubt on historicity of Jesus
now once there one more thing that's not
how religious people use the word faith
yes let me give you a big the what I
don't know let me just attempt it
because I'm just I'm I think we might be
deviating from maybe the point I was
going to I understand that religious
people might define faith differently
but I guess what I'm saying is the way
you and I would define faith I feel like
as someone who again is mostly on board
with your assertions about this issue
that the line between what we know and
what requires faith is maybe not as
clear as you sometimes make it out to be
and I think your replacement of or your
use of the word suspicion is now that's
a new word where along the spectrum does
suspicion fall between faith and know
before we hold a whole week we got to
back up because this this these are huge
things that we have to unpack okay we
don't say that we have faith that the
laws of gravity apply in Alpha Centauri
or some other correct more remote we
don't say that right we say that based
on the best available evidence we assign
a confidence value to that belief you
don't even need suspicion we can take
the words suspicion is too late in any
way but we assign a confidence value to
that belief how confident we are that
belief is directly proportional to the
evidence we don't need to extend the
confidence that the warrant of belief
beyond the confidence of the evidence we
don't do that anything else we don't do
that with you know how fast jaguars run
so so why would we do why would we do
that when it comes to claims for which
we had even less evidence it makes no
sense whatsoever unless you look at
these things as moral claims as opposed
to empirical claims so like look the
problem of induction about you know we
extrapolate from the past Bertrand
Russell has some great stuff about this
we extrapolate from the past to the
future and assume that in the future the
future is going to resemble the way what
happened in the past and we do that
because we've lived in the past and we
then extrapolate from that but you don't
need any faith whatsoever from that
radishes started you know sprouting into
or where I bit into an apple and it
tasted like a roast beef sandwich sits
Bertrand Russell's example that we
wouldn't need any faith whatsoever that
faith is specifically a word that people
use when they do not have sufficient
evidence to believe something but they
believe it anyway that is the depth that
is how people actually use the term and
you don't find physicists using that
term in regard to phenomenon that happen
in remote corners of the universe
let's pause our conversation there with
dr. Peter Boghossian we will be back
after the break with plenty more